I find myself thinking all the time like
I wish we would return return voting
rights just to like married men who own
property because if you had to be
married and own property and like to
vote I feel like our system would be
totally different to start yeah
so that part and then we strip those
guys yeah
Dave's here you see the Family Guy joke
about this where it's like it was a
flashback and then it's Peter Griffin
talking to someone and he's like you
know okay you're free but you can't vote
because it was like Civil War or
something and then he was like only
white people can vote except for then he
starts naming all of the other groups
that technically like and it's like you
know what no voting for anybody nobody
can vote like that's where else well
look I mean I will say that I think
um look see if you're the only person in
this room or maybe I don't know about
this but like you would be our voting
Block in this room right and if I was
the only person in the country I tell
you I'd be really on board with this uh
plan but well look if you look at say
like zoom out say like the last hundred
years broadly speaking like go to like
Woodrow Wilson's Administration to Joe
Biden's Administration and you just look
at how much bigger the government has
gotten like in all of these increments
right you have like the creation of the
Federal Reserve and the income tax do
you have fdrs uh the New Deal you have
the expansions during World War One
during World War II you have uh um you
have the Great Society under Lyndon
Johnson you have you know whatever
everything from there George W bush and
Barack Obama and all the way through to
the present and you look at how much the
culture has like like been degraded and
it's not a coincidence that like as the
state expands your culture gets more
destroyed if you look at it through
every inch of it right like through even
the creation of say like Social Security
it's like okay well without Social
Security what used to be the retirement
plan well the retirement plan used to be
your kids would take care of you so
you're just like incentivizing people to
take really good care of their kids so
that their kids then want to take care
of them before the rise of the welfare
state what was the welfare state it was
your local community it was your local
church it's like there's all of these
incentives to kind of like we build
communities for a reason because there's
natural incentives for us to all work
together and kind of like be
interdependent and then the state comes
in at every turn it like undermines like
all of those cultural norms and and like
incentivizes you to be dependent on the
state and it's horrible how uh where are
the politicians campaigning on just say
like ending the income tax yeah I mean
it was unbelievable to me that during I
mean I was screaming at the top of my
lungs for as many people who could hear
this but even during the whole like uh
during the all the covet Insanity
they're like hey you want to figure out
how to get it's so funny watch the
federal government say we're trying to
figure out how to get Aid to the
American people who we rob half their
income from like how about
three years of that we're pausing the
index address you know like a tax
holiday for three years but something
like that and and why no one would be
you know talking about this thing that
is the biggest bill for so many families
around the country it's but but think
about this they did the stimulus the uh
they did the extended unemployment plus
the stimulus because of covid and the
the complaint from a lot of people was
that Democrats are basically bribing
voters saying vote for me and I'm gonna
give you money
okay so one Republicans would be like
we'll get rid of the income tax
Libertarians I mean obviously but you
know conservatives should be campaigning
on that they get every vote if if you
can if Donald Trump came out and said
please you don't like me I know but I'm
gonna abolish taxes on you so you'll
have a lot of free money then Democrats
might be like oh I hate trauma I'm gonna
vote for that guy well tax cuts do tend
to be popular I think that you know the
issue that people have with it is that
if in order to do something like that
you people would recognize that there'd
have to be drastic Cuts in spending
along with it because our government
just spends so much damn money and so
nobody wants to touch that including
every rep every Republican president uh
of my lifetime including Donald Trump
trump should do it yeah I look I agree
with you Donald Trump
needs to do a campaign video where he's
like wearing the cloak and he and then
there's like fires behind him and he's
like I am shutting down the Federal
Reserve the income tax Vengeance will be
mine I'd be like I'm going for that guy
well it's just the most insane I mean I
love this is a Scott Horton's analogy
not mine
um but so shout out to the Great Scott
Horton
um but uh he always says this which is
just when you really think about just
how insane the income tax in the IRS are
especially in a professed capitalist
country but he would go imagine the
Soviet Union invaded and conquered the
United States of America so we're a free
country and the Soviet Union invades and
conquers us we never had anything like
the IRS before and then they come in and
they say we are creating the USS IRS uh
it is now a crime to produce something
it's a crime to make money in this
country and the punishment for the crime
is a fee and the more you produce the
higher your fee goes and we've repealed
the Fifth Amendment you no longer have a
right to not incriminate yourself you
must incriminate yourself every single
year to the government who will then
assess what this what how much you've
produced and therefore what your
punishment should be how high your fee
is and if you lie when you're
incriminating yourself we will throw you
in jail and if we feel that you if we
decide that you've miscalculated we'll
go back 20 years and just absolutely
destroy you like if that was the case it
would be so obvious to all of us what
happened we went oh we were conquered
and now we live under totalitarianism
yet we our own government does it to us
and people are just kind of like well
this is a government Department you want
to know why I'm absolutely sure
and it's soon enough everyone's gonna
have the neural link port on their necks
and they'll be plugged into the Matrix
of the metaverse because we all have
government mandated identification
numbers multiple of them you get your
driver's license or ID you've got an ID
number on that card but when you're born
they give you your official government
tracking number congratulations now that
that like think about that analogy about
Soviet Union and go back a hundred years
and people are going to be like the
government's going to do what yeah track
me by number what now it's like everyone
has one it's totally normal so it's
going to be normal this expansion it
just keeps happening the the likelihood
in my opinion is is 100 well the thing
about it is is that like like uh
parasites tend to eventually kill the
host and I was thinking of maybe a more
optimistic metaphor than that uh but
there there it does seem like something
we're living through something very big
right now and Empires do collapse and we
do seem to have all of the signs of a
collapsing Empire but I got a better
analogy not parasite symbiote like Venom
okay actually I think it is a much
better uh analogy because if you think
about it for those that are uh you know
for those that are fans of Spider-Man
you'll probably understand this do you
know anything about like the Venom
character no I don't the the Symbiote
attaches to Eddie Brock and then tells
him it's going to give him everything he
wants make him powerful get his revenge
makes him more aggressive and angry
that's literally what happened the
United States had this this group come
in the Jekyll Island say we're going to
do this thing it's going to stabilize
your economy it's been so good for you
it's going to make everything better and
then turn the country into a weapon made
it angry and aggressive and imperialist
yeah I mean yeah okay I like that
analogy a lot actually I will say though
I think the um I think the biggest story
in the world right now is
um what just happened over the last
couple weeks with uh uh she going to uh
Russia and working out this deal with
Vladimir Putin they've got Brazil on
board they've got India on board the
Chinese have now brokered uh somewhat of
a normalizing uh normalization of
relations between Saudi Arabia and Iran
it's like you're seeing like in 1991
after the Soviet Union uh collapsed the
late
um evil Charles crowdenhamer uh dubbed
it the unipolar moment
um it seems like we're witnessing the
end of the unipolar moment like we're no
longer in just an America dominated
world and it's it's quite something
that's just like the hubris of all of
these warhawks in DC that one year into
this war in Ukraine and you're like oh
that's not how the plan was supposed to
go now is it but democracy ain't
sweeping the region after we overthrew
Saddam is it but I think Donald Trump
saw this the one of the reasons he
wanted to run securing our borders
bringing manufacturing back was because
the U.S unipolar world was destabilizing
and the only way that people like
Hillary Clinton the Deep state were able
to maintain it was by further spreading
thin expending resources and it was
crumbling and so Trump is like we're
going to make this country great we're
gonna bring back jobs we're going to
secure our borders we've got to get a
control on this because otherwise
if we allow the Deep State Biden
Democrat whoever is is running the show
to keep doing this we're going to spread
so thin it's just going to snap and then
the United States will be left holding
an empty bag if Donald Trump was the
president we'd have more manufacturing
we'd have a secure border and then when
the unipolar shift happens to a
multipolar shift we are still much more
self-sufficient and better off oh yeah I
mean look I gotta say I I think the
world and America would be better off
without America being the dominant like
hegemon like I don't think that's done
any favors for the American people I
think that like it's just allowed us to
expand our resources and spread them
thinner and thinner don't get me wrong
it's been really great for Raytheon and
it's been really great for JPMorgan
Chase and like is it some people have
benefited the average American I don't
believe has
um I think that Donald Trump did see
America in Decline and felt like it was
for a lot of very stupid reasons like
this is what he would say he's like well
we're fighting stupid Wars and we're
making stupid trade deals and where you
know and we're like we are flooding with
immigration this doesn't make sense but
he appreciated how much this was
directly related to the increase in
government spending and the zero
interest rates for over a decade that he
inherited the the reason why the Deep
state was engaging in war and stupid
trade deals is to prop up the Petro
Dollar by forcing countries who would
try to oppose us to to uh Gaddafi Saddam
Hussein they wanted to get off the
dollar they get wiped out the reason why
we were doing these awful trade deals
the the simplest example would
understand this is the Pakistani gender
studies Grant it was like 12 million
dollars for gender studies programs in
Pakistan now everyone laughs and says
it's the stupidest thing I ever heard
but the idea is if the U.S can print the
money and give it out it maintains
confidence in that currency it may
weaken it through inflation but it makes
sure those people use it so you'll get
this country you'll get Pakistan getting
this money of course that money's not
going to gender studies are going to
steal and they're gonna use it for
whatever they want but if you've got a
guy who's just given a million dollars
he wants wants that million dollars to
be worth something so he goes to another
guy and the guy says I don't want U.S
dollars he goes I only trade in U.S
dollar because I'm rich and I got US
Dollars okay fine we'll use US Dollars
the US does this stuff with bad trade
deals giving money away on purpose and
then blowing up to anybody who won't use
the dollar yeah it's over that's over
well it's it seems like it's the
beginning of that of the end for the
Petro dollar now what exactly that's
going to mean I don't know but it's big
they're talking about the cbdc starting
the the Central Bank uh yeah digital
currency in July now yeah there's been a
lot of talk of this they're trying to
gauge it and this is why I say like it's
the most important issue to like spread
awareness about right now so that people
go like listen under no circumstances do
you go for this because what's going on
right now and this is something that
happens a lot is they put these feelers
out and they gauge how much resistance
there is to this but like the white pill
in all of this is that if there's too
much resistance they will pull back this
idea if you remember Joe Biden floated
out National vaccine passports and they
float this out through like their
corporate press outlets and they go oh
we're talking about this and then there
was a big uproar about it and then they
pulled it back they go no no we were
never talking about doing whatever
talking about Obama announced that we
were going to invade Syria there was a
huge pushback to it and he pulled it
back we didn't invade Syria we only
covertly funded Isis but that story for
another day uh but even with uh like
sopa if you guys remember the plant the
original plan of regulating yes that's
right uh they they floated this out
there was too much resistance and they
pulled it back so like there is actually
a lot of power there's a reason why they
try to propagandize people there's a
reason why they use propaganda because
they recognize that they actually do
have to like have at least a level of
tacid support to get these policies
through so like the Central Bank digital
currency is the big one right now to me
like oppose that as vocally and as
loudly as you can how they feel like
they have to pull this back because
that's game over for us thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast fast hang out with us live
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and become
a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time